[Music]
guess who's back with the new battle
mage
GPU Intel you could you can read the Box
this is the
b580 it's the Intel Arc B it's okay
technically this is Arc B series code
name battle mage 12 GB of gddr 692 bits
pcie Gen 4
interface realtime Ray tracing
capabilities there's a lot to like here
for $250 Intel has made a lot of
promises a lot of very very tall
promises and we're going to put it to
the test this GPU basically promises to
give you a reasonable 1440p gaming
experience even with Ray tracing though
you might need frame generation this
could enable gaming on a relatively
inexpensive machine you could
be giving this as a gift or receiving
this as a gift this holiday season for
reasonable gaming computer this is going
to redefine what $250 is assuming that
Intel can get the software right and
make sure that the game support is
topnotch and that all of the other stuff
is in place there that is a shockingly
lightweight card it's got flow
through flow through cooling has a
single eight pin power interface so it's
very very low power you could upgrade an
OEM system and this is a full display
port 2.1 graphics card well almost full
this display port output that has the
line around it is the higher higher bit
rate display port 2.1 well it's
13.5 ubh but for the specifications like
okay so you can do 8K or up to 4K 360
htz on the display port with the outline
and the other ones can just do 240 HZ at
4K because the amount of bandwidth
varies that's technically allowed under
display Port 2.1 but the full fat
display port
2.1 is like 20 gbits per Channel and so
you could get even higher frame rates so
there's different bit rates of display
port
2.1 and not very many monitors on the
market there's you know 4K 360
HZ there might be like one OLED that can
do 480 HZ at 4K right now at the time
that I'm making this video but I digress
this is not this is not this is your
1440p card this is this is the 580 it is
the successor to the a580 this is the
b580 this is not something you pair
really with a 14900 k or a 9800x 3D or
the highest end gaming CPU either it's a
$250 GPU you put most of your money into
the GPU and less money into the rest of
the system for gaming oriented stuff if
you do lightweight gaming or occasional
gaming or Esports
titles this could make sense where you
spend a little bit more on your CPU you
get you know that higher end 12 core 16
core 24 core whatever and you need
something that H you can do some light
gaming on $250 it's a reasonable Choice
with three display port out plus the
HDMI 2.1 now that HDMI 2.1 that can do
4K 120 HZ 240 HZ and Beyond because HDMI
stuff HDMI at those bit rates uses
display stream compression so it's not
exactly an Apples to Apples comparison
that we're talking about for bandwidth
but let's get to the gaming benchmarks
which we will Benchmark with a higher in
CPU because that makes sense for gaming
benchmarks but I also want to touch on
some benchmarks for some other
reasonable configs two configs in
particular one with our pixio 1440p OLED
display because OLED is the butter for
your eyes option there are also very
affordable 1440p VA panels such as the
ASRock Phantom gaming panels we've
reviewed in the past that would also
make a good pairing with this GPU
because you know maybe you're not ready
to run 4K and that makes sense because
$250 GPU this GPU is designed to compete
with $350 to $400 gpus but again only
cost $250 which is uh inline a bit less
if you take into account inflation with
the launch price of the a580 so the b580
brings according to Intel's
documentation 33% 25% to 33% more
Performance Plus rate tracing reasonable
rate tracing performance rate tracing
performance that Intel promises is
significantly better than AMD we'll put
that to the test in just a minute at the
same price point so let's see now I
mentioned unconventional build ideas
with this card let's talk about that for
a second this system is based around a
commodity inex expensive mini Forum
motherboard it comes with a mobile CPU
basically this is a class of lowcost
typically lowc cost not always
motherboard that comes with a mobile CPU
soldered to it sometimes they can come
from AliExpress they can come from other
vendors mini forum is one of the more
reputable vendors and even with that
you're not going to get as cohesive as
an experience as you would from ASRock
MSI gigabyte and Asus in terms of you
know fully baked platform but this
system at times like this kind of a
platform the the the AMD 8 core I think
the lowest price that I saw was $359
this is an Intel mobile I9 13th gen the
lowest it was I think was $3.99 but
that's the motherboard and the processor
and everything and that is a really good
deal for that level of performance so
you can do that very inexpensively and
end up with a machine before the GPU
that's on the order of $6 $700 uh this
is in a a designer fractal case you
would not put it in a designer fractal
case to save money you you would want
most of your budget again to
go to the GPU or as much as possible so
a used OEM system could make sense like
you might be able to get an i7 or an i5
used system with a single 8 Pin power
connector
and that would work fine for the setup
the only reason I'm not out here at
recommending the ASRock desk meet is
because this won't physically fit in the
ASRock desk meat that is a Bare Bones
system is what they used to be called
where you get everything except the
processor memory and everything you got
to add your own processor to that but
there are ways there are ways while
we're waiting on Halo infinite to uh
resolve some texture Shenanigans because
hey the Intel drivers haven't had a
history of being absolutely perfect this
whole time but they've gotten better
faster than any other gaming GPU in
history let's talk about power
management so a common thing that has
happened from both Nvidia and AMD cards
is if you're running a display that's
capable of 120 HZ or even beyond that
pixio display man that is really capable
of some very high refresh rates it
dramatically increases the amount of
power the card uses well not this one
total board power as measured by me is
about 13.5 Watts at 120 hertz running a
single display or about 7 Watts running
a single display at 60 HZ and so if you
are a Casual Gamer and and you're
somebody like me that likes to have a
bunch of very large high resolution
monitors this card could make sense just
because of the power savings alone it's
not adding heat to the rest of the
system and everything else runs
exceptionally well so that's pretty
awesome that they've factored that in
keep in mind it's also only eight PCI
Express Lanes eight PCI Express 4 lanes
and that comes with an inherent cost
savings and power savings as well and
all of that is even before we take in to
Advantage XCS to and the upscaling
Technologies and also sort of the uh the
full montia I don't really know how to
explain it but Intel is taking a tiered
and complete approach with the drivers
in terms of latency and reflex type you
know the Nvidia reflex like how quickly
does it respond even using some of
nvidia's technology to measure their own
in-game latency and it's like you can
turn on XE low latency mode and it's a
little too early for me to tell how good
that stuff is but I can tell you that
the XE upscaling technology is quite
good and so I was a little skeptical of
okay if you have an older toddle like
say Borderlands 3 this is actually a
reasonable experience even playing at 4K
now it's not 100 FPS but you can
generally maintain 60 FPS using those
upscaling Technologies and the driver
feels a lot more mature both well well
if you remember the way that the a770
launched like it launched and it was
kind of rough and then like 2 months
later they had a major driver refresh
and that really dramatically improved
things this is pretty good out of the
box like this was a genuinely fun
gameplay experience even turning on some
of the more advanced frame generation
and upscaling Technologies frame
generation and upscaling are two totally
different Technologies but both of them
I think have large software teams
working on them because this is an
impressive level of Polish and again
Intel has come a very long way in very
short order it's interesting that these
gpus don't really directly challenge
Nvidia performance per se but
objectively I think with the rate
tracing experience it does actually sort
of kind of I mean this is a $250 card
but it shows that raate tracing which I
think on Nvidia cards is basically
treated as an afterthought unless you've
got a 4090 is actually a reasonable
experience on this GPU it's shocking I
mean even comparing rate tracing on
something like the AMD 7600 which is
also a little bit more expensive of a
card older sure but a little bit more
expensive uh the rate tracing in this is
actually usable whereas on the AMD side
generally I've said like the 7900 XTX
and 7900 XT the highest end cards are
the only ones that really give you a
good Ray tracing experience
this is not like an amazing rate tracing
experience but it's not terrible it's
pretty good for what it is it shows a
lot of promise and I also like present
and what Intel is doing there in terms
of let's make the graphics pip line a
little bit better and a little bit more
sane and lean on Microsoft to do certain
things and and that and certain other
things with the Vulcan interface there's
also really a lot more overlap in the
driver stack between AMD and Intel H
then really anybody would probably be
comfortable admitting I mean Intel has
done a lot of software engineering sure
don't get me wrong but the approach with
Vulcan and a lot of the design
philosophy that AMD has given us as
opposed to keeping things more locked
down if you look at Team Green's
philosophy has enabled Intel to move as
quickly as they have I think that's just
my opinion but I can point to very
specific technical things the driver
stack and with Vulcan that make me think
ah yes not to say that I think AMD has
made a strategic mistake I think it's
absolutely a necessary thing to do in
this ecosystem but for better or worse
because of this Intel and AMD are a
little bit Frenemies when it comes to
the driver stack and the ecosystem
health and building something that's
reasonable for developers when we're
talking about an actual real gameplay
experience at the same time Intel does
have a lot of Special Sauce in their
Hardware when we look at what they've
done for their shaders and what they've
done for the caching and what what
they've done for the close coupling
between the driver architecture and the
Silicon well it has borne a lot of fruit
that they're able to do this at 210 WT
board power it's very very impressive
there is a somewhat minor fly in the
ointment and that is if you have an
older machine so I've set up a 10700k
here and I've done testing with the ark
b580 as well as the RX 7600 the RX 7600
is still out matched and outclass by the
b580 to be clear but the software
overhead and the driver and the advanced
features of the b580 don't work quite as
well on the older CPU and in games like
cyberpunk as an example but this is true
on games that have a lot more CPU demand
you get into a situation especially in
this 10700k where it seems like the
graphics driver is competing a little
bit with the game for overall
performance uh it's better than I
expected but it's still not fabulous so
it's not a silver bullet if you have an
older CPU and if you're looking at our
general performance numbers which were
done on better more modern CPUs you may
not get anywhere close to the same
performance on an older CPU uh bottom
line modern games on an older CPU with a
Cutting Edge GPU where they're really
pulling out all the stops on the
software side the b580 um can be not a
fabulous experience that's still better
than the RX 7600 the RX 7600 8 gigs of
vram it it's at the end of its life
cycle an AMD has got something loaded up
in in the queue but not not a good fit
here either even though it does suffer a
little bit less than the b580 when we're
talking about older CPUs and older
platforms that may be something to visit
in another video or something to look
for specifically in other reviews is
like hey what CPU do I have am I
considering this for an upgrade has
anybody done any testing specifically
with that CPU hell hit me up in the
Forum maybe we can put something
together with your specific system and
just see how it goes like what's the
performance look like how does it
actually work as long as it's still
generally better than competing cards
it's fine and that's what I found with
the RX 7600 it's still better than an RX
7600 it's just not better by as much of
a margin when you're suffering with an
older CPU platform is what I'm trying to
tell you there's some Nuance lost in
that explanation and some subtlety and
some detail but bottom line now
benchmarks before we get into the
benchmarks I want to just tell you up
front I'm going to do something a little
different here instead of going through
25 or 30 games that I play tested
because this
is you know I want to say it's player 3
entering the game but player 3 entered
the game a while ago but what I want to
make sure that you understand is that
the engineering team behind this GPU has
different engineering goals than the
other gpus that are available and so I
wanted to cherry pick a couple of titles
to start with and to start that
conversation with 1080p 1080p games at
the highest preset if we look at this
it's like okay Shadow the Tomb Raider
180 FPS versus 158 FPS of the 7600 this
isn't a bad start the biggest detractor
here is the 7600 is old news and the
7600 was not amazing when it first came
out it was okay but the price point this
is a much more aggressive price point a
year later than the 7600 if we look at
Boulders Gate 3 81 versus 84 FPS 7168
depending on if you're using Vulcan or
direct X11 this is a little bit of an
impressive result if for no other reason
than when Intel first launch to their
Ark line of gpus like the a770 H direct
X11 performance uh maybe not amazing but
this is a really good result All Things
Considered and then we look at something
like Warhammer 40K it's like 686 4 4340
again these are 1080p results and it's
like well okay the card's going to be a
little bit cheaper but that's you know
last generation card like is is AMD
going to have a $250 price point we know
Nvidia is not we'll talk about that too
in a second but okay I mean this is fine
but this is extremely misleading this
taken in a vacuum doesn't actually show
how good this GPU can be let's take a
look at cyberpunk 2077 now cyberpunk
2077 is a terrible game for a a lot of
reasons in terms of benchmarking and
everything else but doing our own run
through at the city center where the
performance is really not amazing 1080p
with no RT but on Ultra so FSR quality
frame gen on 196 FPS this is very good
and this is the best visual Fidelity in
this particular game FSR quality with
frame gen off it's still 129 versus 107
FPS this is a pretty substantial uplift
for a a car coming in at this price
point XS quality with frame gen off 127
FPS and no upscaling with frame gen off
is 99 FPS I wouldn't have expected this
big of a spread between FSR quality and
frame gen versus no upscaling and frame
gen off 83 to 99 versus 167 to 196 at
196 FPS with FSR quality
the game play the actual gameplay
experience was very very good and keep
in mind this is 1080p now here's where
things get really interesting RT Ultra
turning on ra tracing like ra tracing is
the thing yeah Intel apparently needs
needed to show everybody how it was done
I guess cuz this even beats the pants
off Nvidia for the low-end cards for R
tracing this is almost like a 4090
experience not really that's a little
hyperbolic this price point but yeah 119
FPS now this is frame gen and FSR
quality but this was also very playable
like the gamep playay experience with
this is what I really wanted to drive
home and that's why I'm sort of doing
the benchmarks a little different
instead of going through 30 different
games the gameplay experience was very
very good shockingly good FSR quality
with frame jent off we still managed 70
FPS and 72 FPS with xss quality and
frame gen off with everything off it's
23 versus
40 That's still a doubling it's double
the performance even in a worst case
scenario but how do you go from 40 fps
to
119 that is the level of software
engineering that has gone into this and
in terms of real actual gamer gameplay
experience that is shockingly good now
that is not to say that cyberpunk 2077
did not have its weird quirks with this
card but that was down to cyberpunk 2077
for one uh constantly going through and
changing the graphic settings could lead
to game instability and sometimes I
would have to uh hold the key I think it
was like F1 or something when you start
cyberpunk in order to get it to recover
from a bad combination of graphic
settings but cyberpunk was the only game
well cyberpunk in F1 2024 were the only
games that I experien any kind of driver
weirdness so good job speaking of F1
2024 the spread here is also very very
impressive and keep in mind this is
1080p we're looking at 1080p 1080p is
actually the least impressive of the
results from from The Arc b580 but this
is still a very impressive result
overall I would not be as enthused with
this card if the other Graphics results
or the other Benchmark results sort of
followed suit with this but let's take a
look at 1440p 1440p 93 versus 109 7168
okay balers Gate 3 uh it's not it's not
dramatically better but it's also not
dramatically worse and pretty much no
game that I tested was no notably worse
except possibly Starfield cyberpunk at
1440p was a very playable 134 FPS now
the thing that I want you to notice here
is wait a minute 1080p 1440p this card
doesn't scale resolutions the way that
other cards do if I've got a 4090 and
I'm running at 500 FPS in Shadow of the
Tomb Raider at 1080p oh it's going to
perform really well in 4k this card
performs about the same I mean Real
World gameplay experience not FPS
numbers and 1440p as it does the 1080p
so Intel when they say oh this is a good
card for 1440p what they mean is that
the numbers don't look as good at 1080p
but the 1440p numbers are amazing and
that's probably owing to the GPU
architecture and the engineering choices
that were made here 130 140 FPS of 1440p
on the the Canada track wet is very
impressive on ultra high graphic
settings now what about RT Ultra on
cyberpunk 2077 78 FPS this is a a very
very good result I was also very
surprised by the result from the 7600 68
FPS this is a huge improvement from AMD
because with FSR quality and frame gen
off it can only manage 20fps
subjectively the gameplay experience on
the
7600 with FSR quality and frame J on not
as good as FSR quality frame gen on on
the new b580 the 3D Mark scores were
overall pretty impressive time spy as
well as were other productivity
benchmarks things like blender and
geekbench and the pic Creator Suite so
this card can hold its own in Creator
workloads at least versus cards that are
8 gig and a little constrained like the
7600 so yeah I maybe it would make sense
to split out the actual raw Benchmark
results into its own video but
subjectively uh my experience was better
than I expected with this card by quite
a margin this is a solid card for doing
1440p gaming with AAA titles I was
shocked by that but also just the gaml
experience the card feels a little
different than Nvidia and AMD cards and
this is owing when you run it with
everything like if you just want to run
the card with no you know upscaling no
XS it is not as impressive so overall
the game benchmarks are pretty
impressive and yes I've Cherry Picked a
few game benchmarks but depending on
what the game is it's going to fall into
one of those categories that mostly it
performs better or quite a bit better
and the regressions are minor to
non-existent there are a few bugs with
xss but overall it's very good but this
card also plays nice in the FSR
ecosystem so yay FSR upscaling
Technologies at least in the quirky
specific cyberpunk scenario which is
atypical but still worth talking about
in my opinion yeah
so let's ramble a little bit more about
all that so what's the bottom line This
is a firecracker of a card the
performance is incredibly impressive
generally it's a sweeping win uh at
least when we're talking to price to
Performance ratios from both AMD which I
focused more on and Nvidia Nvidia is a
different conversation we'll talk about
that Nvidia has a different product
strategy but overall it is a shockingly
impressive card one on the software side
with the technologies that the Intel
team has managed to uh pull out of a hat
in terms of uh lowering frame latency
present Monon like the engineering that
has gone into that this is a software
team that has moved at an incredible
Pace second Intel has priced this thing
aggressively I can't imagine the margins
here are uh amazing and I worry about
that a little bit with Intel's Board of
director and everything else that's
going on at Intel but it's a solid card
and whatever they've done on the
software engineering side of things it
shows it
shows amazingly this being a 12 gig card
as an entry level card is also amazing
because you know Nvidia consistently
wants to give you as little vram as
possible uh some have criticized that as
planned obsolescence I think there's a
little bit of Truth to that meaning that
the GPU is uh slower than you want um
before it's really like at the end of
its lifetime like computationally it's
fine but doesn't really um it's not
really able to run the latest AAA titles
now Nvidia for their part I think part
of their business strategy and mark my
words going into the 5000 series of gpus
is to sell you less Hardware because
they think they're going to make it up
in Superior software I don't think
that's a valid like my personal opinion
on it is is I would rather have more
hardware and let the software improve
that as a business strategy selling you
less Hardware with better software is um
not something that I as a consumer of
that Hardware would want because if I've
got the hardware and I can make up for
it in software then you know let's go
but over the last 5 years if you look at
options from AMD and then later Intel
there is a little bit of Truth to that
which which sucks for AMD but Intel is
coming in fast with a software side and
apparently very competent team able to
move very quickly if they're able to
crank out the kinds of things that we
see and to go from what we saw in the uh
the arc launch The Alchemist launch the
original Intel GPU launch to where we
are now in 2024 the other worry that
Intel has is that they're the first out
the gate we know that new gpus are
coming from AMD in short order and we
know that new gpus are coming from
Nvidia in short order what are their
offerings going to look like Nvidia for
their part I think their approach is
going to be more less is more which
means that what Nvidia wants to sell you
for $250 you know Nvidia knows that
they're the premium brand the thing
that's $250 is going to be slower and
worse but the software may make up for
that in nvidia's mind AMD AMD is a bit
of a wild card here has AMD learned
lessons and and moved their uh software
team ahead like have have they done the
needful in the reorganization like what
does AMD have on the software side how
aggressively is AMD going to price
things maybe amd's sweet spot is going
to be that $3 to $500 graphics card the
7900 XTX at the at the highest end is an
amazing card the weakest point is rate
tracing of course and so what is AMD
going to have for Ray tracing for the
$250 option if you're after the graphics
fidelity what's going to be the the 12
GB option is the 12 GB vram option going
to be their opening Salvo their opening
you know configuration for
gamers that's the question but right now
today if you had to buy a graphics card
today this is a firecracker of a card
it's shockingly good and it it's
excellent in newer and even middle-aged
systems it's maybe not a good choice for
older systems it's it's definitely not a
good choice if you can't enable reside
bar or you don't have the BIOS options
for it like you're not going to have a
good time using this as an upgrade for
an ancient system and even an older
system will suffer in ways that you
don't necessarily expect but Ving there
this is a really shockingly good card
good job Intel good job Intel
programming team it's really shining
through and the hardware is pretty good
too nice competition yay I'm what this
level one I'm signing out you can find
me in the level one forums let me know
if I missed anything or you have any
questions he
[Music]